Right thank you.
My name is assembly member
Reginald Byron Jones
Sawyer senior.
Assembly member of the fifty
ninth assembly district and I
have the honor to be in a chair.
Select committee of boys and men
of color.
Normally I begin the meeting by
traveling down but I don't see
my gavel.
So I guess this is now
officially my gavel.
So this isn't an official
hearing. Of for the Calvin state
assembly.
.
I would turn it over a little
bit to.
My partner and justice are Todd
Gloria who.
You all know because he's
from here.
.
And so.
This hearing today arm is
identifying the improvements in
the status of boys and men of
color.
Living in San Diego.
I'm
really excited about being here
at the San Diego continue
education
north city campus.
NCC I don't know in CC means of
multi purpose room.
This is.
A beautiful facility.
This.
Everyone here in San Diego
should be extremely proud. Of
not only what's going on here
with the continuing education
but the fact that.
We've put in.
Money in efforts to build a
magnificent facility so I.
I wanted wanted thank.
De Michelle gray for for
wealthy in here.
Today our it's deathly and are
up to be here.
A de select committee on boys
and men of color.
.
And the reason why I like to
mention is have been around for
for almost ten years.
And we like to mention that
because Sandra Swanson in the
assembly lower care bass.
And who speaker and then.
.
A jumper as.
Really form to select committee
boys and men of color Sandra
Swanson who is from the bay area
recognize that we were city far
too many. After American Latino
API and now we've added native
American boys and men of color.
School to prison pipeline
and we needed to address it.
Of no disrespect
two the president United States.
Brock Obama.
What we know so you have now?
Not note
specter held.
California.
First.
Actually.
Actually have hearings.
Really start doing things.
For they was a to sons and
brothers that were started with
the Barack Obama.
Glad he.
Started in the start on national
level. But you should all be
proud.
That this discussion started in
California
and I wanted make sure that you
knew that.
This is my first hearing of
this year. We've had six
hearings.
Mike.
My tenure is every two years so
which side.
Do thousand seventeen two
thousand eighteen.
We've had for several first we
had our first meeting in San
Jose.
Seaside and Oroville.
We had our first hearing.
With a Republican
member.
As the host of
committee.
We're not like Washington
we actually talked to the other
side. And we have to work with
them in a constructive way.
But most important which.
Some ways we we we.
Embarrassed about but we had our
first
hearing on native American boys
and young men.
Which incidentally you need to
know what's the most watched
online viewing of any hearing
out of all the selected maybe
Harry's that we ever had.
And in fact that it brought
tears to a lot of individuals I.
Because it was so impactful.
And and learning to challenges
of native Americans I think
would not only very formative.
Of I think it also ultimately
opened our eyes that would
probably needed a whole lot more
a lot sooner.
So I I am extremely proud to be.
Chair but I'm also proud.
To.
.
To welcome assembly member I
know you
calling him
counsel.
Ali known as assembly member
Todd Gloria he's a great Allen.
And de um California State
Assembly
he actually understands.
The issues that only impact his
community but other
disadvantaged communities.
When I vote.
All I know you have to look over
I know how it's going to vote
which is the right way.
Which is for finale for you.
.
When he's in Sacramento you just
need to know. All he talks about
is making sure San Diego is
taken care of and you should be
very very proud. To have a
measure assembly member in
Sacramento
what that assembly member Todd
Gloria.
Thank you Mister chairman.
They could is kind was Mister
chairman and welcome everyone to
this hearing I am glad to see so
many familiar faces.
To share what we've done in San
Diego what what we must do.
With our chairman.
And.
.
Chairman John Sawyer dozen is
very kind say those words I
appreciate him tackling the five
and talk to us. On this is level
commitment.
That the legislature has I'm
working on this issue.
And high.
Gratefully toast this.
In San Diego I know that my
colleague it's.
Some of them are doctor Shirley
Weber will be here soon aye she
nine account tag team today's
hearing you know when you're at
home you got a lot of demands
your time but I really want to
be here. To so the seven eight
assembly district support for
the select committee on you
would be surprised that.
I sought out an opportunity to
be on this committee I as the
legislature's first native
American Filipino water weekend.
Assembly member.
I feel like I'm holding on the
minute color piece a pretty
good.
And and I recognize our special
concerns within our community.
At their structural historic le
challenges that we've yet to
overcome but.
Our chairman and our committee.
Have been given the opportunity
by the voters of our districts
to make some important changes
in as I was chatting with many
of you before I the chairman
came to.
Star are meeting.
You know hearing from you that
concerns around mental health
around recidivism outcome of
justice reform. I will tell you
these are issues that we talk
about every day in Sacramento
and Casey we get to act upon
into.
And there are a number of
things any of you who may saw. A
governor brown state of the
state address.
Yesterday he's been a
significant amount time talking
about issues about come on
justice reform and try to set
people up for success rather
than continual failure. And some
of you live that out and I
really appreciate the stories
that were shared with me
individually help some of you
will share that with the
committee.
.
As we go for the hearing.
But the stories are important
because they help to change
policy and that's really why
we're here today not just an
area grievances but a real
sharing the stories. They can
help us to craft legislation to
improve people's lives athlete
quick one.
In our chairman was a leader on
this particular issue.
Of banning the box and some of
you probably know what that
means a lot of you probably that
in a situation we've applied for
employment. All you got a good
interview but you can get the
job simply because of a criminal
background.
That you couldn't clear it's
interesting that you know if you
don't ask that question on the
front end.
You tend to be able to get the
job.
And so California we vote we
voted that we approved in the
governor signed a bill to
eliminate the box of that
question is not asked.
When you apply for the job you
can work that out afterward if
it off of an offer employment is
made. Aye best transformational
for helping people actually get
jobs to be able to make the rent
a to meet your responsibilities.
And that's legislation that came
from the community from folks
who've Y. live this life and
walked in the issues that people
like Reggie and I are here to
listen to. So that we can find
the next piece of legislation
that will improve people's lives
and give our men and boys of
color a fighting chance. At
succeeding in this.
In this world I wanna shout out
to junior like things in the
very back you told a very
compelling story about that
changed its possible people
believe in you and I you given
the assistance.
We won't have a lot more
engineers in California that's
of this committee's about unsexy
you honest with your time.
This afternoon get my apologies
for when I have to leave once a
doctor Weber rise.
For this important work and
appreciate cynical shown up in
force to let our friend from the
north you some LA but will hold
that against him.
Before.
For giving us the leading the
committees here to this
important issue that is up to
not too often not discussed.
But increasingly is heard in
the halls of the state capitol
and I'm gray Friedlander voice
to making. Make yourself heard
today submits chairman thank you
again for all the time and
trouble god bless you friend
drive back to LA tonight.
That really shows commitment.
In his wallet you know a we
have a very good chairman here
who's going to make sure that we
get more good legislation passed
up to Sacramento. Thank you very
much thank you touch that and.
And ends so that you know. That
did these discussions.
Sometimes can
turn into reality bandbox is
one.
Laws a will for defiance no
longer young boys just be in.
Thrown out of class* nilly
by by school administrators are
teachers.
But I want you to know this
year.
.
I've been going all over.
State and in.
And I was hearing from a lot of
young people about the mental
health. Of our young people in
that kind of drove the men.
To some some situations that are
not that good a young man came
to my office.
I just got out of prison after
being then.
Jew now for three years and in.
Three years in prison ask him
what he did.
And he said it was for assault.
So I said what happened he said
look my parents one was on drugs
only to jail my. My brothers
sisters rider.
Selling drugs are part of gangs
so I really didn't have anybody
at home.
I was hungry so I gave me five
dollars I get to school my
stomach rumbling.
Kids are laughing at me you.
Just gonna leave class and go
and I get something to eat.
While is grabbing his use that
Taco Bell la used just about
every time we talk about it as
is grabbing.
His burrito hand reaches over.
And he just naturally.
Pledges back and hits a police
officer in the face.
It's not I've got assault.
No.
Solana police officer Mayes
cookbook at.
So the show management three
years and you about three years
in prison.
Because he was hungry.
Think about that because he was
hungry.
Have because we don't have a
school psychiatrists social
worker. Or anybody can deal with
their mental health needs.
So I.
He said look I've been
traumatized he said you know you
talk about post traumatic stress
disorder. Citing have that I
posed dramatic St.
This order.
And so I decide to write a
resolution and it. Was to put it
will tell you if you do
resolution I can make a
resolution that dishonest purple
and I'll get through.
Frazier Friedman no matter what
this one took six months.
Because the professionals just
descended on me and told me I
couldn't diagnose anything
because I'm not a doctor I don't
have. I do know what goes on in
my community but I can't.
Diagnosis.
So they want to call it ace is a
trauma informed care assiduous
fine I just need.
Figure out a way to take care
of.
Even even though they denied us
having a hundred million dollars
for boys and men of color.
Because a prop tool nine.
We can't do that anymore we get.
Direct funds directly to people
of color.
So we decided.
That this year after I got the
resolution through.
That we would ask for a hundred
million dollars.
Post traumatic stress disorder
to help boys and men of color
and girls and women of color.
Who've been traumatized in there
disadvantaged communities
to help them deal with that so
they can better able.
Matriculated on a link to to
school but to be able to. Deal
with.
Situations and and.
In a communities lot better.
I'm telling you that because
Raskin for that hundred million
dollars today.
Your testimony.
Could be a pivotal.
Example of why we need.
So that's why it's so important
for us to get your testimony is
so poured for us to go all over
to state.
And not just good LA
Sacramento that we actually
reach out and have you up.
It to us
so with that. Will have our
first panel.
On youth development.
I have a Kevin Malone.
San Diego organizing project.
Author Soriano youth
empowerment.
Luiz over here Louise.
Lucio. A SCO es I ask I a tech
high and Ernie Silva SIA tech.
It's good my hat.
Yeah.
Floor.
And you have to share my.
And also to make sure I.
Introduced Ryan Lindsay who's
from other colleague the office
of.
Alright Lorena Gonzalez Fletcher
is here.
But.
And calmly got. Office of
assemblyman Brian Maienschein.
Them Mr Maienschein is a member
of the can.
So whoever wants to go for.
I'm I'm first.
I it's good to see all your
faces out here many of you I
know.
I'm Kevin Malone I've had the
privilege of working with the
San Diego organizing project
for.
More than fifteen years.
Our work is to build powerful
organizations in congregations.
That.
Begin to live out their faith
in public life.
And I'm part of that peco
California network that does a
lot of work.
Around the state.
.
So we were there when this this
commission got form more than
ten years ago and what I was
afraid of is. Is that.
It would be a commission where
impossible problems go to
disappear. And I'm happy to say
it doesn't feel like that at all
that some good work has been
done through this.
Normally I wouldn't be here
today.
.
My job is to train leaders and
clergy to to.
To be the person who speaks
Arabic I got challenged by my
African American friends.
To be the face today.
Because it's important for
white allies to occupy the space
and named the the evils of
structural racism and white
supremacy. That under gird this
entire conversation and.
We need to be the ones.
Changing it to.
And we need to be in the spaces
and and be brave enough to say
we're not there yet.
And it hurts us to.
I like what more fee it's in
the mid and from the movie the
matrix said that the matrix is
cage for your mind.
And racism operates like that.
Were all in cages the cages
look differently.
And we're learning more and
more about.
That that.
The. Nature of that cage at
through conversations like
these.
.
And this one just like noodles
me I I can't stop thinking about
it and you all know it because
your experts and I see so many
faces I've worked without here.
But but drama can be passed on
genetically.
Lake.
Noodle on that for a minute and
and and imagine what we're
really up against.
This is a long term work and it
burns in me the last sixteen
years as.
Director and organize your
nasty O. P. this is banned in
the center of our work.
The cradle to prison pipeline
before people are using that
language I think we were.
I'm also here because we have
failed.
I think we've made some strides
in the last decade.
.
So I can remember being in the
meeting of criminal justice
reform advocates in in
Sacramento fifteen years ago.
When I said the problem is prop
thirteen reduce investing in
communities caller.
I laughed out of that room.
I was also a rumor said that
hate if we don't if we don't
talk about money bail reform
we're never going to get
anywhere I got laughed out of
that room to.
People said we can't fight that
and and I'm happy to be here to
say that we have taken some good
strides.
And for me this is a.
Some to give me many men.
Thank you.
A third of my son's friend.
It.
Another third or in that it.
Jobs another third written
military.
And.
.
So.
I know that I have failed.
This system is failing.
Everyone.
And I I going to I only got
three minutes that's not a lot
of time.
My work with a lot of pastors
so give me an extra minute.
So make make no small plans for
they have not the magic to stir
one's imagination that from
Daniel burns and I think we
don't dream big enough.
I I think we need bigger dreams
if we're really going to address
the violence of poverty and
racism. We need bigger dreams
and and we need to start
speaking to those dreams and
naming the evils that we're up
against.
So we must talk about universal
basic income.
But is it we must begin to think
about. Changing how we employ
people we must begin to value
teachers and pay them better and
hold them more accountable. We
all know these things.
We need universal high quality
preschool.
We need to have been.
Universal healthcare and we need
to talk about the social
determinants of health that
determine where young people of
color going and we must name
that we must invest in our use
we must. Invest in these poor
neighborhoods
criminal justice reform your all
experts on it we designed a
system that incarcerate
incarcerate incarcerate and
there's never conversation about
real ability.
It's the second you walked in
somebody gave you a hug and said
you're forgiven now go forgive
yourself and repair your
relationships what if we had
that kind of system.
In California Pico California's
leading a conversation that's
called heat.
If we're really going to
transform law enforcement we
must hire differently we must
equip differently we must hold
the system accountable
differently and we must train.
We'll differently what if every
prison guard was a trained
mental health experts.
And what if what if every police
officer had two years of
training. And. And and
tendencies towards aggression
were identified right like they
do in Finland. I know I'm
running out of time here we
we've done some good things prop
47-57 the support of you in and
the great doctor Weber. And and
all of her work and we must do
the bail Reform.
We must continue to expand
alternatives to detention they
work we must expand restorative
justice programs like mid city
can has they work.
Ian Gordon created with our help
a youth development office here
that's massively under funded we
must expand work like that and
diversion. Last thing I'll say
I'm running out of time there's
a good program and to the best.
South Bay community services we
want a promise neighborhood
grant out. And it is working. It
is working investing in families
investing in and their jobs
investing in the school's
wrapping these communities up
with a massive in and out
inundation of services changes
outcomes.
But you have to do it all.
Wrap up please. Alright.
I have more ideas for good
things that are working but I'm
sure there's going to talk about
it.
Thank you.
I am a boy of color.
I am a man of color.
I'm a boy that was raised in the
juvenile justice system.
And also a man that was raised
into incarceration.
Presented by plan.
Now I'm a family man I'm a
father.
I'm a community service deter
you know founder of you think
part of it.
My story began. Five years ago.
I got out.
A did fourteen your screen went
back in out of the system.
In out violations got to wear
the terms.
I got out.
And I began to work on my so
that pulls dramatic.
Trombone.
I began to identify were to come
from and I began to heal from
it.
I had a compassionate.
Provisional officer by the name
of Jay mac which is a midi mac.
Cheese.
Husband.
And he showed me compassion he
showed me love you show me war.
So be opportunity to get on the
right direction.
I was on AB one or nine.
And I was able to get off in
record time six and a half
months.
I discharged my first time being
able to get away from this is.
So I got away from the system.
And an unfortunate situation
where my son ended up in mercy
hospital.
I weighed and the.
When I was there are officer
leave John Cooksey which was.
Used to work for the mid city
police department.
And I seen his compassion his
love that he was showing towards
my son.
And so.
I let him talk for like five
minutes but he made the
connection.
And then I told him my story he
invited me to our mid city
police department are in city
heights.
And.
My wife and I we took a leap of
faith and we walked in there.
My nervous system was out of
whack is the first time I have
been to a police department on
these terms.
But I Nguyen my give it a shot
so we walked in there.
And I seem of Sir John Cooksey
and our Dana brown and see
wrapped around me and showed me
love. Compassion made me feel
welcome.
Within a month.
I was out in the community.
City heights.
Every Sunday for two years
straight what Krystle sound upon
I.
We're at the Roth apart. Every
Sunday
connecting with the.
Boys of clutter men of color
grandmothers of color and just
on a grassroots effort.
Which is reaching out to our
community.
Within that time.
Were able to build relationships
the most important the
relationships of the community
think gauge of the community.
Matt what pro bass and.
Build relationships with them.
County the city.
And we formed and we grew.
And we'd we filed for the.
Nonprofit which is in the
process right now.
But our works and our fruits of
our labor.
Paid off
and.
Through the Latino coalition
the department of labor.
They were able to see work
grassroots community work is
being done in the community.
So you from parliament and of
project aware stood out. As
being a to grassroots
organizations.
There are working with our boys
of Conor and our men of color.
So we began this grant were
approved for it we got the
grant.
A for a three year process and
we work with the population of
a.
Eighteen through twenty four so
we provide workforce job
opportunity.
Education resources for these
young adults.
And we also reach out to their
families as well.
And but the the beautiful thing
about it.
Is that before their grant even
began.
For the salary began.
All these efforts.
Were put into the community
the relationships were bill.
With the young man.
The boys the grandmothers of
color to will now. The grant.
It's easy.
It's easy to do.
It's easy
to be able to recruit or pass
our numbers were exceedingly.
Of you know these are individual
community mentors with they've
experienced what records under
jackets.
But we're doing it we're we're
doing it and we're getting. The
job done where it needs to be
done. And we're reaching out so
although referrals our community
because for the community by the
community so there's great work.
Happening in.
Incendio county and of Regina I
partner up which is let the no
after gin American coming
together. To help our boys of
Conor so. I believe been
dreaming dreaming big and at the
same time challenging him
holding people accountable that
need to be hold accountable.
Their leadership. That doesn't.
Have that compassion and love
how things need to be so thank
you I hear from my trombone I
yield. Missile about being
resilient thank you.
And did you.
Please. Turn off your for your
phone.
Because of all here bringing
sometime budget hearing.
Sure fits
you are me here.
And we also have Stephanie
Allen.
A field representative for a one
Congress. One guards.
Welcome back.
I'm I'm Bernie still from
scientific the school for
integrated academics and
technologies on thank.
Think Kevin an arson for sharing
their stories and for the great
work fifty do and and the San
Diego area how thick the
committee and staff for inviting
us from sci tech to come and
share.
We are a drop out recovery
charter high school network
it's a lot. I'm we focus on a
and re engaging students who
have been out of school. That
means of the students that we
server typically five to six
years below grade level their
very low income and the
predominately Latino and African
American.
It also means that they've been
subject to.
Post traumatic street yes
Austrian disorder and so what we
do is we work with
partners to try and provide a
full range of services
we have three locations here in
San Diego were at the job corps.
More in north San Diego
Oceanside and we're here in
South Bay in Chula Vista.
I'm we have will be one of talk
about the improvements
identifying improvements and
positive in trying to be bring
for the positive. I'm education
code forty seven six twelve
point one allows
schools like mine in partnership
with department of labor another
job.
Development agencies to serve
kids that are over I'm nineteen
and so that's what we do we have
partnerships with the job corps
of the department of labor. And
with a number of other
organizations.
And I've got a couple of pieces
of paper that I've.
Shared and I'm going to bring
out I'm one is this thing from
of the alliance for excellent
education
the talks about the benefits of
green gauging dropouts here in
San Diego and the extreme amount
of.
Revenue as well as just a house
of making lives solid the other
piece of paper is this aye aye
I'm gonna just.
We could mention is.
This site to graduates page I'm
we have over.
Two thousand we have.
Nine thousand eight hundred
forty two former out of school
youth who have graduated with
our program.
We have one thousand nine
hundred twenty four since
opening in.
Two thousand here in San Diego
the job corps and we have
another.
Fifty found that if I graduate
the last couple years from.
From our our program.
What? What the the other piece
of this and the the the the data
that you know is out there?
About re engagement and what it
means for the community.
Our numbers that nineteen
hundred and some means that
we're putting back into San
Diego region
seven point what over seven
point one million. Per year and
the gross regional product.
It's not just about it's
important it's not just about
building families rebuilding
communities it's about what
we're doing for the economy and
for the and for those families.
I'm I'm going to introduce
Louise Louise this year who's
one of our students
I'm typically were. Serving
opportunity if sixteen twenty
four Luis came to us a twenty
four so he's.
Couple years older is twenty
seven now I'm he's gonna
graduate this year were really
exciting lacrosse and.
Left school before become the
breadwinner for for his family.
AB we have I've
I've assured him that he's among
friends arm the this this
a story that we're gonna that
I'm gonna give in and he's gonna
talk about some out. Is that
Lewis is a citizen. I'm not all
members of his immediate family
are a part our citizens are
documented so we're going to
kind of let you know that I'm
Louise lives on both sides of
the border. He.
Has family on both sides but
he's attending school here is
planning on going to college
here. I'm we're really proud of
him and he's going to talk a
little bit about what the how
important it is to come back
into school in with the school.
Has done for him and what he
likes about working in a in an
nontraditional setting.
That soon.
But. Hopefully we prepare them.
Hello everyone my name is lose
lose him I am twenty seven years
old. Eye rolling to say I think
when I was.
Twenty four years old I Mister
Silva save us blocking the two
thousand fifteen right now I am
about to graduate.
There is one subject finis risk
based on difficult thanks so
that I am this close finish.
Hopefully.
As I am going to.
So I'm here to talk about so I
think.
Is not the traditional school
people like me that passed to
work almost a full time to pay a
rant.
To take care of the family.
Doesn't have enough time to be
there will time.
Starting.
So say they gave me the
opportunity to earn credits at
my own speed.
.
Which I am so grateful for the
offer that because one cigarette
they then want to be able to get
a per job a better paid which is
a.
They're paid which is what it is
going to contribute to. The
economy itself us until.
California.
Institution like this.
I have to continue.
Because.
Perhaps county new on the fish
then there are making a great
work with all the students.
In fact I am so glad that I
found that school in my darkest
hour.
I remembered that I was looking
for a better paid job that I
didn't have a high school
diploma.
And.
I have always been a person that
likes to learn likes to.
Not to be in the same spot.
To move on. To.
Keep growing up up like keep
keep growing like like a person.
And. That's it I'm so close le
once they finish in the school
library to transfer ticklish.
I would love to study for
Ringling sheath
right now I am.
Stunning Japanese.
Wish it could be kinda hard but
I love it I like to communicate
that we in another language.
All I can speak in English I lap
of languages type.
Love his country.
When I see people.
I don't see colors I answered
races.
I see launched people that it's
working hard to gather.
To make.
Healthy Philip this country.
To make this country stronger
to.
Going on.
To.
Develop skills off other
people's
and.
I think.
The fifth.
Gloria.
I request that I would just ask
the members the panel and. Thank
you by the way for. Your
testimony and for what each of
your respectively doing to
advance the concerns of this
committee. On Kevin I think was
a. Are a light touch my life and
policy priorities I'm some of
which I think we may tackle this
year specific bill reform. Was
curious maybe for each of your
question of what would be if you
were in our shoes what's the
number one legislative issues
would want us to tackle in.
With Isabella form needed I
think money go formally
grandstand or hopefully many of
you understand what that is but.
Of for each of you individually
since you occupy different
spaces of of of this issue. And
what would you ask us to go back
on Monday up the capital and
work on space.
Whether there's two there's two
things of. Violence said one but
okay.
That the individual with the
record.
.
Breaking that policy like Kern
you we have a planning its of
two we have all top probation
public safety.
A part of that that planning is
to and when have a document that
we're going to be able to
present.
And that is that people would
live experience records that are
a bit it.
In the community and doing
great work that they be given
the opportunity to.
Be able to get contracts and
Exeter and work with the boys
and men of color. As far as
specifically for this grant.
Were blowing this thing up the
park and our biggest need.
For this you for young adults
eighteen to twenty four. Has
been. Half of them are homeless.
Their culture for.
Thank you.
John how I'll go ahead and jump
into.
So again my of my.
Lance is re engaging. And so
what I what I think the most
important thing we can do is to
provide a. Incentives new
resources tattooing to increase
the partnerships between schools
and other community services so
that you can address harmonise
homelessness and mental health
issues and all the rest. Their
work we're trying to do
hodgepodge but we need resources
and and more support from the.
But I got a long list of the
been shortened Ivan. So there's.
Really I didn't get to this year
but there's good work happening
here to blow up you know how I
just said that I don't mean
blown up I mean scraping it.
And completely transforming
juvenile hall into a.
So I think I don't know what
state enabling stuff lies in
there. But the other really big
priority is the marijuana tax.
That their resources the twenty
percent that goes to law
enforcement.
Percent that's supposed to be
focused on use. Gets targeted
into a use reparations model.
The drug war differently
impacted communities of color.
These resources need to be
invested in those same.
You in season.
Would.
Did you want to add.
Yeah. I am I'm sorry mom I got I
got along they but yeah it's
it's I just want to support our
third one of our goals locally.
To support emerging
organizations led by those most
impacted in led by people of
color. It is very difficult for
the small organizations to find
support at the county. And the
state levels and we need to
figure out how to do that if.
With think a panel on and I'll
just leave you. With this.
The assembly on the chair of
public safety.
Chair of public safety budget is
Dr Shirley Weber.
And my.
The other like our counterparts
is a need to Skinner who's over
both budget and policy public
safety.
A we have a goal.
And I've.
Crafting a but do something.
Said and.
We've been saying that we.
Before we leave.
We want to do something it's
never been done before which is
close to prison.
Never been done we building like
crazy. We build a more than we
build universities.
A but we never close one.
So we've we've readjusted it
based on.
What I'm hearing is?
Maybe.
We changed the facility.
State of it being a prison will
be education center a campus and
and the nature I would love to
talk to you.
Each of you give us input.
On as we reduced.
The footprint of the number of
people there Carceri difficult
problems
forty seven fifty said
rehabilitation.
How do we build these new
facilities for education
rehabilitation and?
Homelessness and and so I would
love to follow up if you follow
that our staff on this
again I think the path.
So on our education panel.
Would like to bring up Frank
Harris and Luke would San Diego
State University.
Are masa de Niro Macedonia. Are.
Are the aga junior.
.
Is Valley at.
Suelo de la Raza.
And so de Sadat Ali African.
Coalition workforce.
I.
I Frank in Luke first.
Harrison would.
Sandiego state.
Doctor Weber.
Former.
The university.
Weber here happens.
Not that way.
Well good good afternoon.
First one.
And I'll join you with my car.
Both.
Back here said it was state
university.
Mission college.
College.
Assessment lab colleagues CO.
And we do work on on education.
Thank you.
We do work that focuses on
equity related education issues
that impact. The status of boys
and men of color up. Primarily
focused on community colleges
but not exclusively focus on
communicable edges.
So I became the data share some
the days we've been learning
from that work for for nearly a
decade. I'm exhausted eyes as
well as to discuss a potential
recommendations and next steps
about.
Things that we can do as a
community are you know perhaps
with the support of our assembly
members that are here. To really
reverse.
Some adjust the perverse
patterns.
Of of inequity that we see that
impacting boys and men of color
and education lose going to
start. And then I'm going to
pick up after.
So we have a lot of different
projects going on in terms of
research that we're doing with
one just highlight to that we
felt were practically relevant
here.
First with.
Doing a lot of work looking
statewide at men of color
including housing insecurities
was of mines.
With the previous comments but
specifically looking at
community colleges
if we think about. Of post
secondary education the vast
majority of our men of color
concentrated not in.
Places like San Diego State
University or any of the UC's
our in our communicative.
So it serves as a primary
pathway to post secondary
education.
Unfortunately like many others
educational institutions.
There access is not always
synonymous with their success so
it committee called the struggle
to be able to do that.
A one of the reasons that we
see.
At one of the factors that we
see is influencing their success
is up food insecurity housing of
security.
So in our most recent report
the.
We had come out.
We found that nearly.
Twenty three percent.
Of black males
struggle with food insecurity
now there's different types in
ways that that can be measured.
About lot we look at
specifically it our work is the
most acute form of food
insecurity so students who. Are
struggling with where they got
what they money.
And there's different ways in
which is measure but we look at
the most acute form.
So we have about you know again
to it twenty three percent so
nearly a quarter. Who struggle
with that challenge we look at
housing and security which can
include a wide array of things
to come?
Some was student whose
couchsurfing Suguna Karsavina
closet in some sort of untenable
living situation we're looking
at forty eight percent.
So there's a number of reasons
why does rates are so high.
But they are very high those
issues are also typically.
Aligned with other challenges
we know that for for example
students who experienced food
insecurity.
Seventy five percent of them
three quarters are also an
experience housing and security.
To also very likely been
experience transportation
challenges
as well as a major employment
barriers
so you're talking about a
population that is experiencing
pretty significant challenges
and one of the. Things that we
do is we go around we talk with
a lot of educators about what
they can do to better support
their success. And a lot of it
begins with perception
stay a an educated much Houston
and back and the classroom comes
in a little bit late.
You know we know that student
may have all these different
things going on and their very
presence demonstrates their
resilience and the fact that
they're committed in they care.
The educators sees them I like
seeing. Their always like their
lazy they don't care they're
only here for the financial aid
so allowed where we deal with
our issues of. Perception of
barriers.
The other thing one mention
there's a report that we've been
doing.
That's going to come out. In
February so very soon that's a
partnership between our center
the seal commute because equity
assessment lab. And blackmail
institute well what Tyrone how
did you silly looking at this.
In case twelve in California I
know this probably lot of folks
near done work around.
Exclusionary discipline issues
in general they fall into two
different categories in terms of
exclusionary discipline students
or suspended. And score out of
school or students who are
expelled.
We are been looking at
statewide data.
And we see that of the statewide
average for suspensions is three
point six percent. For black
males its twelve point eight
percent.
The highest disparity if we
start looking at different
levels so those who are early
childhood or middle school and
high school. Is actually in
early childhood where they are
five point six times more likely
to be suspended.
We also know that when we start
doing to segregation's we see
really high rates among those
who are foster you. Those who
are homeless.
And we also in our report tried
to identify places where this is
occurring so. If we're thinking
about how total suspension
numbers behinds places are
usually are large urban
counties.
So we're thinking about places
such as Los Angeles Sacramento
county San Bernardino county.
But if we think about heists
expansion rates it actually
occurs in rural counties where
there's less rep representation
of. Of black males and the more
likely to be isolated and have
experiences
where based upon these rates are
being clearly being targeted.
Yeah so we're regard to
recommendations are you know
they're December that we thought
of first to address
recommendations related to food
housing and securities thank
you.
Are we have to continue to
invest in the community colleges
first and foremost recognizing
that.
For boys and men of color it's
the primary pathway to a
bachelor back to.
That you know without that
investment.
You know the students are not
necessarily going into see
issues are you see S.
attentions.
If they're access in those
institutions it's through to
transfer so have to concede
invest are the equity. By the
side of invest been invested a
committee colleges over the last
couple years has done a lot to
address concerns like food and
housing insecurities among other
things.
So we opted to can you continue
to see that as a worthwhile
investment. In our state are
will serve to think about.
Investing with regard to
facilities in committee colleges
of things like residents halls
meal programs childcare things
that can help reduce the cost.
Of attending college but also
to help students meet other
needs
that impact their ability to to
access I'm affordable food in
affordable housing given things
like have been free meals on.
But think about our K. twelve
schools we have free and reduced
lunch programs.
You think about how might that
that same same type of.
Program be implemented and a
post secondary level.
Again would regard to the
suspension concerns that lieu
talked about intensive ongoing
professor development for the
our teachers in our state is
absolutely critical. Are so much
of these disparities relates to
things like on crutches bias and
things like racial micro
aggressions so we talked a lot
about.
You know that as it relates to
life force where we have to have
the same conversations about
weight what occurred within
schools.
But we have to consider look at
data and use data to inform
drive these conversations as
well. I don't think about some.
You know statewide task force
to focus exclusively on.
Spigen expulsion at other types
of exclusionary disciplinary
programs.
So with that.
We're going to concluding allow
other colleagues to share their
remarks and hopefully have some
twenty four questions and
dialogue that
much.
Thank you I have twenty pages of
notes that probably won't talk
about anything I wrote down.
I want a survey thing no.
I was really excited when I
pulled into the parking lot and
I saw reserve that make I
thought it was for me.
.
And the other was a young man
next to me and our cities this
when we park on one of the
speakers is it dollars solely
for the politician.
.
Swimming next about how reserve
spot.
I'm kidding I'm I don't need a
reserve spy I'm I'm good.
.
I.
I always like to start with with
some humor less just part of who
I am. And.
In our in our native.
You're talking about the
reservation in our native.
American ways of seeing the
world.
Humor is
sacred medicine.
Without it we we just
find more difficulty to function
in life nam.
Both of my brothers went to jail
my father went to jail stuff for
males I'm the one that.
And we went for a night.
.
None to my brothers.
Finished.
The ninth grade. When I got out
of high school I had a fourth
grade reading level had a fourth
grade math level.
Super long story short I finally
changed my life like turn my
life around I went to college I
graduated from you.
Steel is an honor roll student
ash and even know what honor
roll was when they sent me a
little paper set out on a real
student.
And you know what that was.
.
So.
I think that's what begin.
The work that our.
I'm not gonna say me because
there's a lot of people that
that did this work that we
started doing in the community.
For many many years with that
putting get any funding and. I
know a lot of you in this room
are in the same situation.
With a give money to take kids
through the reservation from the
city or are we start a rite of
passage ceremony it's over
twenty two years now that we
have liberty a rites of passage.
We know everybody in this room
knows that that we all go
through rights of passage in our
lives we go through them.
Different stages
so we provide a healthy rites of
passage with our young men.
The young Chicano boys and some
of the African American boys we
literally taken to the
reservation for three days as
there.
Finishing their rights of
passage they get a crazy Nick
name just like because that's
what we have to do. Is get crazy
nicknames arm.
But I think everybody's been
talking about it is my the love
this song the of.
Was.
Over my classes here the.
.
Post traumatic stress disorder
right I love that. And dom I
think one of the things.
Is helping them understand.
Why their disengage helping them
understand why they feel the way
they feel because young people
don't understand? Is that low
I'm stupid  I'm this all on
that is sick.
We don't.
We don't have to tell though my
their disengage.
The key is to help them
understand why this and they
disengage
I had a student a couple days
ago so I need anger management.
Okay what is acre.
Well I don't know what is anger.
Paying.
Okay what is pains other and
they just start they break it
down themselves they start
realizing that.
They don't have to blame
themselves that generational
trauma. And and.
Young people to start learning
this it may th grade and sixth
grade seventh grade we can start
healing no young men they don't
have to go to a therapist.
Every single time we could do it
in a circle we could do it the
way our answers of it too in a
for.
About five thousand years you
know who little bit before the
war restorative justice came out
restore circles.
I'm so what I want and with this
because I know my time going to
come up soon. We know.
That something happens to young
men of color in the third and
fourth grade we know by then we
know that would have to get it
to everybody here knows that.
So if we're going to start
talking about initiatives we're
start time of funding.
Imagine a real genuine one
hundred percent campaign that
says you know what. There's
something happening at this age.
Well I'm billboards bus shelters
were weak genuinely are.
Going to the root of the
problem.
Which is something is happening
in some of these brothers
already mentioned.
Unconscious bias right.
It's genuinely there's teachers
in a measures that are afraid of
our young people they're afraid
of me and it's like I don't
don't freak out I work here you
know.
.
Not the janitor but I I work
here and.
So. That it's real I know like
it's that it's it's kinda
humorous but it's real so.
Imagine a genuine campaign will
we start really attacking the
root root of the problem what's
happening because the majority
where a little boys are going to
tell me they go to elementary
school.
Something happens there.
I still have yet anybody to
pinpoint what really really
really happens.
And I myself racked my brain
trying to figure it out.
I've talk to every scholar you
could possibly imagine may give
me different.
Their ideas right but we have to
all the brothers that are here
today. This is less started
committee let's really genuinely
figure out what happens
because that's it.
The plant that seed that corns
coming out of the ground and.
COR is not going to grow it's
not growing so what would is it
will kind of fertilizer do we
need how much water does that
mean.
Right how close we have to have
it away from the shape.
We have to figure that out
what's happening with their
young men so.
.
Like the like that other brother
was say now he's around pastors
around a lot. One the
reservation we sit around our
elders talk to three in the
morning for four hours. And
we're not allowed to move or not
allowed to fall asleep.
So believe me I could talk for a
really long time is what's I'm
used to that but thank you thank
you.
Alright thank.
Good afternoon now.
First thank.
Chairman Sawyer assembly member
Gloria.
And.
.
Give everyone here give yourself
a hand of applause for all the
great work you don't.
And.
Special shout out to the
Californian down.
Mark Tran in the back for.
Being one of the one of that
honestly one of the best private
foundations to take this.
Issue and make a top priority
so.
The California endowment and
apply.
I wanna.
My name is Sadat Ali and. I
found it African coalition
workforce to.
Foster economic growth and self
sufficiency.
Basically through you know.
Underserved populations so
providing job training.
Employment placements.
So we worked not mailing list.
Refugees and immigrants and
city heights.
Will also get a lot of college
graduates that walking. With
the.
Don't teacher you know some of
the basic life tools in college
so.
I'm as the issue alumni also.
.
So despite all the stuff that's
going on in the news and in the
media take.
.
Special tabla boys and men of
color.
Before while.
You know if they should with the
law enforcement.
And.
.
Forget about education
employment you have to.
We
what about how to survive in the
street.
With the you know the P. T. S.
the you're taught what chairman
Sawyer.
So.
There's a lot of issues when it
comes to this population. And.
That includes
all of us that this panel.
Clued myself I came I came to
the US.
In the mid nineties
at the age of nine years old.
I don't speak one word of
English.
.
I was raised in a single file
full pan.
Single market.
With five other siblings.
So. You see lots of you know
with the fair we all have.
.
Boys and men of color majority
wealth in a single households.
.
With with that said.
You know.
I was very fortunate enough to
beat the odds.
.
Because of.
Likely my mom had a little bit
of educational background from
back home.
So the kids education is.
If one of the main pathways to
opportunity.
And this kind of the about
education.
I'm fortunate enough to work
with high school students right
now providing help three
pathways.
So local city heights high
schools.
We.
Try to put the. Focus on.
And the.
.
Minority high school you.
Get them interested in the
health field.
There's gonna be over two
million health coverage jobs in
the next ten years.
So stuff like alternative
pathways.
Where? We can go to post
secondary that only a four year
degree.
That only two.
Given the options and
educational when I say Hey there
are other schools they can have
to succeed in life.
.
And that's the thanks to the
support the Californian down
some of the great stuff they
don't need city I.
And.
.
So basically it's it's.
Does a whole lot of money out
there.
.
A lot of money to send a was
well.
But not too many things being
done.
Terms of.
You know there's two minarets a.
Politics as usual. Out you know
let's be honest little of
ourselves if if.
We have the local workforce
development of region.
Was a lot of money that can
easily.
You know.
Fund so many of these great
projects in this from.
.
You know
state politics as usual federal
is even worse.
So there are them the monies out
there will need to keep.
Talk about so many hands and and
and and nam and bring in the
south you know. Months after
months.
It's just about how do we align.
Some of these great
recommendations that were
brought up here at this hearing.
Which includes.
Staying in the career path we
trust.
Who state level?
That's one.
Recommendation that's really
helpful
specially career. After
opportunity.
How do we?
Leverage the local workforce
dollars.
In the community.
The the we abolish the federal
funds.
For this young man.
Things twenty four year old
will.
And at the same time.
You know.
Developing high agreements in
the region.
So a lot of these employers.
For taking advantage of
subsidies.
Given employer subsidy.
Subsidized terms of high boys
and men of color.
And it seems on. We can also
take. That affect couple months
ago.
County of San Diego the mental
health services that.
Has a lot of money over twenty
million thousand reservists.
Hasn't been touched for years.
And will you talk on a matter
health issues and this
population.
You come out lack of employment
if somewhat educational gap.
It's almost decided pressure.
Someone law enforcement.
Portsmouth to others not be part
of it.
So the mental health services
act that could be another
component.
Dollars that can be used in
terms of.
And we talked about it with
county level.
In terms of workforce
development creating
opportunities.
So and at the same time going
you know short term program
certificate programs.
.
I want to community college
myself and it was really
helpful.
I think.
With these to professors with
their don't section one.
Community colleges.
One the folks on that in terms
of giving them the resources
they need.
And.
Making sure because a lot of
young men of color bone.
Too many colleges right now
which is the right way to. Kind
of figure yourself out before he
entered the you know.
Crazy four year world.
Universities and stuff.
So with that said.
.
Very fortunate to be here and
well I think everybody. Thank
you.
We're now joined by the assembly
member Dr Weber on a fiscally
ducked were more likely
assembly.
One they think person same
person.
Would you like to.
Say a few words.
Now just double you know.
One assumes that what is in
your hometown is easy to get to.
A and that it's not because
people assume that you're in the
city so they keep one to meet
with you. But I'm I'm pleased to
be here today and I one thing my
staff and and Mister. Jones
Sawyer staff organizing this
item off the chancellor has been
by Constance hero via I met with
her earlier. At noon and she was
telling she's gonna come by and
that she was very on it that you
were in one of their facilities.
We have an amazing community
college here in San Diego and
great leadership and so on as a
young man was talking about his
experience. Clearly.
It's a reflection of the
tremendous leadership that
exists in San Diego but I'm just
pleased to hear this is an
important committee.
That meets regularly and the
issues are important and many of
the issues have actually.
Translated into legislation and
that's what's important I
sometimes we think these are
just committees that meet will
talk and meet and talk.
But they don't miss Jones
Sawyer in and private cheers
have taken the recommendations
and translated them into.
Legislation and oftentimes the
legislation is a in the house in
the assembly of various
committees members of the
commission will respond to. The
legislation is how it's going to
affect I know most of our
cultures.
Many of you talked about.
As you grow up become other
young men young woman you.
Whether after American African.
Native American or EP I will
seem to have these rites of
passage.
Unfortunately right now to write
the patches.
Or with gang members and drug
dealers and they have their own
rights.
I even when we had our native
American.
Hearing a talk about sweat
lodges.
And I was all gung ho ready to
go to find out it's seven days
no food.
Water and year.
It is pretty rough and so on.
DESY boil the sense it would
probably need to read
figure that before but I I do
that and now I hear you have to
listen to your elders to three
o'clock at morning. Can't go to
sleep.
But this whole thing of before.
Just whole school system promote
justice systems society.
Racism hit you.
Back them before you went out to
the force before you start
hunting before you.
We cannot put mentally prepared.
Our young people to to be able
to handle that by sitting with
your elders are.
Or for others.
I've always wondered if we ever
could.
Recreate something like that so
that when what is third grade.
We go look a camp.
You know what they're not read
that third grade level we need
to stop.
And get back or you know they're
there which means a whole lot of
problem we need trauma we need
to stop and no start.
Dealing with that or as you city
need housing they're hungry
it is that something.
That.
Possibly put together a few.
To.
To to maybe start is healing
because as doctor Weber said and
many of you said. We've had a
lot of hearing. And we've done a
lot of things
and now we need to start putting
things inaction.
After me hopefully the. The
subsequent chairs and subsequent
meetings are about
implementation.
Of things and so.
I know that was a long thing but
have you any of you ever thought
at least on the healthcare.
What we could do?
The people better mentally
prepared beyond.
Okay thank you a so where you
where you're talking about.
.
Really briefly as we have a
national group through though
one is called the wisdom keepers
of the national court by those
that work.
The wasn't keepers is a group of
African American males.
Native American males.
.
Chicago males.
From all over the country we've
been meeting for about three
years now and we that.
The before the national
composite works been around for
over twenty years and we have
implemented these rites of
passages.
.
Throughout the country right
and.
Now we are working with African
American males and even some of
our own tribes to bring back
these rites of passage is a
healthy rights of passage ways.
Which
help the deal with all the
issues that we've been talking
about so. There is a model we we
actually did a presentation to
president Obama.
.
We did a presentation to have.
So there is something already
out there that we can use as a
model.
Adele all in with this for such
a long time back check I get
really excited like or maggots
actually sit with some men that
are doing amazing work because.
A lot of times you.
I feel so lonely working with
young man because.
The the resources are so I don't
see any other so minimal and.
A lot of times it's you.
It's just you by yourself and.
You know your out there trying
to also trying to get a little
money for this three taking the
kids to eat your wife's that
white you white you pay for the
food and you know I mean it's
like.
.
Twenty six years she's put up
with it you know but arm.
So so it's just something to
think about their is models out
there we do have models that and
we're working with you know with
men of color who are some really
powerful elders in their work
throughout the country so. So if
they're now it's a matter of
building that.
If it the thing that I would add
on that I completely agree as a
lot of good models which you
know rites of passage models.
Bob a lot of folks lot of folks
in this room were doing.
A lot of hard work to make it
happen.
I dearly weekend.
So to get to them before they
experienced
alright so we can do a better
job of holding. Educators
accountable holding systems
accountable.
Because you know you. In many
ways I think a lot of the
trauma.
Is is.
Preventable.
But we don't have good good
systems are good ways to hold
folks accountable.
Serving young man in ways that
would prevent them from
experiencing a
when the young man should have
to.
You'll be traumatized going to
school.
Think about that.
But you know so many of our
schools now do a better job of
preparing young men.
The a better job preventive for
presenting a do for for life.
Given the work force and so
forth so I think it's.
Got a sort of address it on on
But all possible
three to support the programs
and
you know I Daly knowledge them.
But also not at the expense of
holding.
Actors and.
Educators and
police officers in the city
accountable for for serving them
the what if they should.
Thank you have.
Thank you could not have our
panel.
Thank you.
And in our our final a final
panel. At health.
Daphne Watson the mental health
America San Diego.
Dana Richardson.
A community health. Improvement
partners.
And Diana Ross.
Civilian and Diana Ross.
Mitt CD can.
Definitely go for.
Well I what I feel is an honor
to be here today to speak to.
Assembly members and the
audience about the need to boys
and men of color.
Because.
As it makes a mental health we
know that one of every five
adults someone every six
children.
Have a mental illness
suffer from emotional trauma.
The user cho that number is even
higher. Because they experience
in their exposure to trauma in
their homes in the schools.
And in that community.
Just propel them. To live a life
with. Many mental health
challenge.
I've worked in prisons
I've worked in communities I've
worked with.
Many individuals and very
settings I'm and I recognize
that.
Many of boys and men the colors
received mental health services.
Either through prison.
Also institutional mental health
institutional setting.
Very little would. Of these
individuals received a spectrum
of
prevention.
Early intervention. Out patient
care.
And very little innovative.
So.
We really need the San Diego to
really change how we do
business.
Related to these individuals and
million provide quality
services.
But I am pleased to say the same
vehicles on the path.
As we are trying some innovative
approaches.
I kicked few key programs I I
actually one myself and you see
the gentleman with the. Father
child shirts out.
Those individuals who have many
have come from its and
incarceration.
They got onto a fatherhood
program which is really
relational and mentoring.
Up and has changed many I would
and talking to them you see.
How the program even though they
at first didn't think was going
to be anything?
Made a tremendous difference in
the lives.
We also have a. Bit providing
alternatives to kill pro and men
alternatives to detention
program.
We work with kids
who maybe early hitting the law
enforcement
really divert them.
From long term involvement with
the command just so.
And I also have now surfaced
that are going to homes.
Working with the myth probation
news and families in their home.
So that we can address not only
the issues that the children
might be for.
But all that family member the
siblings and really help them
develop of that equality mental
health and.
But really that's not enough.
We know that we are only up to
the tip of the iceberg.
We he oftentimes people talk
about having create his
conversations with links to race
or individual succumb.
But I'm here to say we need to
have courageous.
Action.
Not just compensation.
Because oftentimes those
conversations.
Really just how like the
problem.
But they don't begin to address.
So what does that mean as it
relates to.
I'm are funding or.
Our issue Arab policy.
We have to make them culturally
relevant.
I oftentimes so the cringe of
people think cultural
competence.
Well that's for you internally.
But culturally cultural
relevance means you have to.
Still only be able to relate to
the people that are in front of
you.
And unfortunately
many of our programs a services
just don't do that.
Weeks week retired people as.
.
I'm it unresponsive.
Well it really is that we didn't
respond we didn't deliver
appropriately.
So we have to really make sure
that the services that are
dedicated services from boys and
men of color.
Not program the father the
child.
These men are trained by other
men.
We also help them to see. What
can they do with individuals of
their own race how they relate
to each other?
So we've had fathers minute who
were older men.
Training young amend.
Each will have a gun a Carson.
Help in the private jobs many of
them helping them just a.
Understand how they can lake to
their wives or girlfriends.
And you know something we did
about little but the money.
But we've served over seven
hundred minutes.
So it really has made a
difference
number one program but this
should there are many programs.
Or we should be expanding these
kinds of programs in the
relational way it works.
So I would encourage us to
really all of us have to be a
part of the solution.
And we have to do it in a way
that's really meaningful.
And really men of color have
often been forgotten.
Ugh ugh services mental health
services.
I'm not really here to really
helping them within the
positively.
We have to change.
Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Dana Richardson work
for community health improvement
partnership
organization where Sir it
manslaughter term solutions to
priority health needs.
The collaboration advocacy and
community engagement
slotted be here with you and to
share some thoughts under the
health category.
A specifically I'm here to share
with you about a program that I
co founded a co created. Back in
twenty eleven called the
resident leadership academy.
This program was created in
partnership with the county San
Diego health and Human Services
agency.
Through the communities putting
prevention work initiative which
existed here in San Diego from
late twenty ten to March twenty
twelve. And this.
Fast track initiative focus
largely on obesity prevention.
A couple of things I like for
you to look out for in the
moments I have to share our
number one not describe for you
what the resident leadership
academy program is. How it has
evolved and grown over the last
six seven years number to
describe for you how the are
lazy and forums and empowers
local leaders to make change?
And number three a profile local
level examples of community
driven.
Change influenced by the or lay
and related outcomes.
So the resident leadership
academy as a ten session
curriculum based public of
leadership program that teaches
residents were underserved
underrepresented areas how to
become health advocate for a
lifetime.
Especially as it relates to
address an issue the public
safety healthy food access an
increase in the quality of
physical activity opportunities
underserved neighborhoods.
As far as the curriculum itself
their curriculum. Based training
was intentionally designed as an
educational journey that will
ultimately lead to facilitating
the self determination and
mobilization of residents were
under represented neighborhoods.
Across San Diego to address
their own public health issues
and concerns.
The curriculum begins with
orientation to the environment.
An overview of community
building principles in the
social determinants of health in
this nucleus of learning we're
building a foundation for
action.
In the participants general
understanding that it is the
environmental social and
economic conditions that exist
in our society which are largely
culpable for the disparities and
exit and inequities that exists
in our community.
We believe that environments
matter and that we're
essentially products of our
environment and the health
happens and neighborhoods.
But building a foundation for
action we move on to profiling
for participants a number of
evidence based public health
focus strategies for the
neighborhoods consideration of
which strategies work best for
them. And the development of the
action plan for improving their
communities health. The sessions
include safe walkable
communities crime prevention
through environmental design
healthy food systems land is
community planning and
leadership advocacy and policy
development.
And after teaching participants
about these evidence based
public of focused focused
strategies we transition from
facilitating not education
sessions work sessions. With the
participants were they identify
group roles and responsibilities
collect and analyze data develop
action plans with a vision
mission goals objectives an
outcome measures and ultimately
plan for conducting. A smart
celebration which releases
formal action plans in the
community.
Let us is a high level summary
of a process which usually takes
about ten fourteen weeks
but please know that with our
late we seize every opportunity.
To harness an ingrained in the
minds of participants to help
happens in neighborhoods and
that environments matter.
And we capacity residents for
action by imparting a very clear
and simple framework. For
improving health at the
grassroots level focusing on
public safety healthy food
access and increasing physical
activity opportunities.
We believe the by first
beginning with the fundamental
and basic understanding of how
to improve health at the
grassroots level that the
community naturally becomes more
fundamentally prepared oppose.
To address issues which fall
outside of the scope of
traditional health care services
and western medicine here I'm
talking about the importance of
capacity adding residents.
To address the social
determinants of health.
Which other conditions under
which people are born live work
pray play an age.
Now that you have that as a
background was talk about
outcomes.
And in just the last six years
after the program's creation in
twenty eleven I could tell you
that this programs member
replicated successfully. Over
fifty times in this county
reaching over a thousand
residents and neighborhood
communities
throughout San Diego essentially
launching. Dozens of community
improvement campaigns led by
residents themselves and
somebody's examples include
reclaiming parts from the threat
of gangs violence and other
illicit activities through park
surveillance and reporting.
Limiting alcohol outlook
concentration and presents a
disk
Spencer reason marginalized
neighborhoods.
Building community through
creating a maintaining community
gardens and sections of the
community which were formally
blighted. Advocating for joy use
agreements with schools and park
poor neighborhoods to encourage
physical activity opportunities
just to name a few.
Essentially these grassroots
mobilization efforts represents
a long term sustainable public
of leadership and underserved
communities which is ultimately
what we need to improve the
overall health status. And Hynde
neighborhoods
so consequently of San Diego.
Announced widely known and
understood that with every
additional resident leadership
academy graduate and the
community that the health of San
Diego and proves.
And it doesn't just stop there
in summer twenty thirteen my
colleague and I created a train
the trainer program which
consists of four non consecutive
days eight hours each day thirty
two hours total. And four short
years we've certified five
cohorts totaling seventy three
certified trainers that can
effectively disseminate this
model in the community.
So consequently over the years
the resident leadership academy
family as grow exponentially in
size to become an impressive
critical mass of advocates some
of us are council members some
of us a mayor's faith leaders
members of community planning
groups.
Middle managers and directors of
local nonprofits assembly
locally focused grassroots
leaders were diplomatic
consistent and committed to
ensuring that the community
prospective is hurt. By the.
Local institutions and policy
makers
to make sure that all people
have an opportunity for good
health and good quality of life.
I'll go ahead and stop there but
what I can tell you is that.
There are lays a mainstay in San
Diego and that the good news is
that this particular model
Justin twenty eighteen will go
national through contract with
neighbor works American.
Is process of Mississippi
facilitated successfully cross
culturally with youth groups and
with intergenerational groups
and this created the healing
that we need in our.
Thank you for your touch.
Ross.
Hi I'm Diana Roth and I'm the
executive director admits he
can.
But I am also a fester and.
Amman and
I this issue is particularly
important to me. Of for those
reasons.
It's taken me a long time to
talk about that.
Because it had a significant
impact on my childhood and who I
am today in.
And that's the reality of of the
trauma that my brother
experienced and that. My family
experience interfacing with the
justice
them.
I here in San Diego.
We grew up here immigrant family
speaking Spanish. My brother
into the system. Of pretty young
me start interacting maybe age
twelve I I don't remember
exactly who was.
In over twenty years ago I'm
kinda old now.
But to fast forward today what
is he up to I I can't see that
he's in college accounts that
he's employed.
But this is what I can say
about him is that he splits his
time in and out of detention
facilities.
And.
Living on the streets.
And in and out of.
The psychiatric laca.
And now my mom and her three
year old boy.
And I was still speak Spanish at
home. And it's hard for me to
look at him. And think of what
happened to my brother and
wonder if.
This could happen to him even
though I would try my hardest
just like my mom dad.
To keep him out of the system
and and on path to to being a.
Strong and all.
So we've we've done a lot I
think just the fact that this
exists in that we're talking
about this today. And that
arrest rates are going down and
that we're having these
courageous conversations of
after fee would say.
But it's not enough because the
trend still show that my son.
Whose of a bi racial child. Is
probably more likely to be on
track to the path that my
brother was in the eighties and
nineties than on a path to
career.
If I could say one thing the
power of our great state
government is that you have the
power to enact massive systemic
changes.
And to hold people accountable
for implementing them.
I would urge you to create
policies that institutionalize
restorative alternatives. In the
juvenile justice system as well
as our schools because we know
that something is not working
there.
I would also urge you to insure
that the money that doesn't
needed for youth development.
Resulting from prop sixty four.
Goes truly into youth
development because if you were
to ask and and doctor Weber I
know you know that if. If you
were to take a look at how many
like that might be used in San
Diego. It's more likely to be
designated to law enforcement.
And.
What we really know what's
happening is you suppression?
Also if you're great powers of
influence I would ask you to
urge local entities with their
own taxation measures resulting
from prop sixty four. To create
their own youth development
funds.
And make sure that those
resources and that money is goes
into early childhood education
because of some of my colleagues
mentioned. We know that around
third or fourth grade something
happens.
The education synergy project
has done their research and if
you look at where San Diego
invest their greatest amount of
money.
It's not an early childhood
education.
Health cannot be and linked from
this pattern. We know that kids
who end up in jail or miss a lot
of school.
Have an increased rate of drug
use HIV tuberculosis other
diseases injuries violence PTSD.
Trauma.
And I could go on and on.
Those two things are linked and
there's a myriad of studies that
say so.
In Santiago alone while the rest
is down.
African Americans and people of
East African descent African
descent of in Sandiego.
Continue to lag behind.
Twenty three point seven out of
a thousand people use continue
to be arrested by. And
communities of color it's eighty
seven point six for African
Americans and people of African
descent.
Twenty seven point two for
Latinos and twelve point for for
white.
And when you adjust for
population without means of over
representation in the system and
last time in school.
And this a scary to me. As a
mom.
As my brother and because of
what happened to my brother.
If you ask my brother and you
ask what his health problems
are.
He holds all of these
he's constantly injure the few
times a year that I see him.
He uses drugs to self medicate.
And.
.
There are significant mental
health issues that go without
treatment.
Programs like restorative
justice.
And.
Early youth development have
demonstrated significant
positive impacts on some of
these health outcomes.
Including making sure that kids
I go to school and get on
pathways to career.
They've also demonstrate and we
know this from our own local
study in San Diego.
That recidivism is
significantly lower with kids
who go through restorative
programs.
So it's twelve percent.
Verse says twenty to sixty
percent in the traditional
system.
Victim satisfaction es up.
And trauma and health outcomes
increased.
So again.
I think we've done a lot but we
have a long way to go. And this
would be my wish list a if
something were to be done.
So I by. That and we may have a
couple questions but.
.
I just start with.
So what I need to do to earn one
of them father to child. Looking
shirts.
Ridiculous go badly.
I mean of you work for I and I
know he has got with how do you
become a man of my word.
And then move on so.
And I I've graduated to.
Examine debt.
College money to to that have
one on a cliff if a team.
.
Pray guy gets a cut scholarship.
But you you you mentioned.
.
All poll where Sacramento a lot
of times and that's why these
hearings are so important.
And that would broadcast it out
of the P.
see it are a lot of times.
.
We have colleagues.
Unfortunately some of these
colleagues look like a lot of
people lives in this room.
That don't really understand
restorative justice
Oct Weber and I.
We.
We get a little frustrated
sometimes.
One more try this
supply.
But forget it other African
Americans let you know why this
is so important.
And.
.
It out today.
Bob my nephew.
.
Wasn't court.
For felony.
And and.
It looks like he won't serve any
jail time.
And it looks so real probation
and then at the end of February.
Will work real hard to make sure
you get that felony office
regularly.
Drop down to the misdemeanor.
Of fortunate son you know how
important that is.
And what I tell them. A lot of
them is
we have these people in our
families.
I don't pretend like you don't.
A lot of people pretend like
they don't know who these people
are.
And where they came from and.
And and that they don't
understand the challenges that
are out there.
And so from so if ruling curry
James.
And so I.
I kind of wanted.
Talk about the programs liked it
and I really met the father did.
A child could my.
The one to hear live it more
because my.
My nephew does have a child.
Newborn.
And I want to make sure he can
be a man of his word.
And.
Father to child.
And I know you said you you
started on a shoestring budget.
But it sounds like that's
something we should.
Maybe it should to in every
city.
Because is a lot like his
problem is it wasn't of.
A father.
In his life.
But in the home and I can see
the ramifications of not.
Having a male presence
we're not even knowing who his
father is.
How that effective so if you
could?
Maybe going a little bit more.
On that program I be happy too
I'm the father the child program
and this really is. An.
A small program that was an
afterthought from one of my.
My county colleagues who said
Daffy they got a little bit a
pot of money but he going to do.
And.
I I really wanted to work with.
A design something for men and
boys that was going to be not
just. A parenting program.
But it was gonna be a transfer
formative kind of process.
So I did a search of a model.
That.
Really was working in Baltimore.
Help men relate to other men and
very relational.
They have some connection with
each other.
And through that connection they
get.
Support. Rites of passage.
Power to do better.
And seen for the first time as a
man.
That's positive among other
men's will have had the same
experience.
And then I hired two gentleman
Mister Wooten.
And Andre Jones and they created
magic in the workshops.
It was.
Phenomenal.
And if you hear and you speak to
any of the men up there
that's how you what it meant to
them.
And that now many of them are
alumni.
They have.
She had the old ways but the
children are so important to
them.
But now the family it's
important to them and I'm
motivates them to do better.
It motivates them to stay strong
and motivates them to to do what
they need to do in the that and
the next step and then no
judgments there.
We really but help these men see
that they are on and they are
valued.
And there are people willing to
support and help them.
So through the program we have
let me target medical.
And we have intergenerational
groups them have older men who
grandparents of parenting that
yeah grandchildren. As well as
young men will just coming out
of institutions.
It's been effective.
But it's only been a shoestring
program.
We because we don't look at the
money will cut the end product
what is the outcome.
With insurance.
And I would hope that you will
talk to any one of the men with
the teacher.
You're gonna see.
I I call it the magic that can
be done.
And if have to be done in every
community every group
every ethnicity hasta have that.
Component.
It would have to be done not not
not in them what a damn way.
S. B..
Real these men have to really
see that you care they can.
To all the nonsense
and really value the work that.
You're trying to do with them.
And so. I want father chop of
memory. I would really want to
make a difference for these men
for the first time everywhere.
Innocent eagle we are making a
difference but. It isn't easy.
Because we'd Mister a shoestring
budget but.
We got will look into match
again.
We can make things happen
anyway.
And that's really the value of
the program and we're going to
try to Estado. Girls and women's
program
focusing on them their unique
needs a very different from.
And they have to be delivered in
a very different manner.
So. I'm excited and hopeful. I'm
certainly with you sitting next
to me.
That we could make them.
Thank you.
Roughly how many minutes.
We serve the with a seven
hundred meniscal of of what
time.
Three years three three years
about seven hundred. And your
goal is to reach a mini.
Well executed gave me a first
goal was only seventy five a
year. Leave exceed that by.
Leaps and bounds
so my got my goal would be the
six about two hundred men.
Of color at me for the next
whatever number yes we can do
this.
Because it this a level of
intimacy Evan in the groups we
don't have a large groups of men
so they can really relate we
share with each other may have a
curriculum that is really
designed.
To really.
Empower them and motivate them
to share with each other and
also speak about those things
that were secret. That they
wouldn't share with other people
now they can see it with a group
of men who have the same
experience they have.
So it really opens them up to
really understanding how they
can improve. That's why we don't
have any of them any females
teaching the class.
You have meant teaching the
class.
We also have men who and who
have been in their shoes.
Some of our trainers have had.
Aye been incarcerated them
sounds
and how it can cheer. You also
have it. Out gentlemanly Kiley
from the county was a bale of.
Came to the program so he sees
it from a different vantage
and brings that. To the group.
So it really does work.
And we have an opportunity to
grow the programming and looking
forward to hopefully do.
So what is your budget for the
program.
We started off a fifty thousand.
To fifty.
No it's not a lot of money yeah
I was asking that I mean
no I chair the
budget.
Public safety so these issues.
So it would be helpful if there.
Polls of state
forward because we do have the
ability to
fun things in this is a.
Obviously and an important
project that gets beyond us just
giving money to the county and
then they figured out what they
want to do it. I've been kind of
opposed to that.
I'm more into of.
Nnova of the never seems the
trickle down in a fast enough
great more in any significant
amount of. So I'm more into
finding things at work.
And helping those things to grow
because in that gives as a great
a dividend coming back to the
state. With regards to it and I
think we are very interested in
I've seen. I've read many of
these programs that the state's
main in Pennsylvania
Philadelphia somewhere and they
really are good programs that do
work. And and I think we need
to.
We're looking at.
.
At the state level.
A lot of trying to figure out
how we prevent recidivism.
So the folks who have been
incarcerated don't go back.
And part of it is the connection
in the commitment they have to
the families that they left
behind.
And figure out how to relate to
them because of that at some
meaning to their existence
outside of the institution.
And so.
Our governors committed to
trying to figure out things of
programs and and I am to at that
point committed to making sure
that that. Dollars we put into
communities actually address the
issues that a bear and a higher
positive effectively so I'd be
interested in seeing what you're
proposal looks like. In the next
hopefully the next week or so us
sending it to my office because
we are in the midst of creating
a new budget for this year.
I just want to watch it with.
I would I was talking to the
chief probation officer in San
Diego and he was saying how they
have to multiple problems. One
young man was.
Hip and has been in and out of
prison he finally got.
Really acclimated to the
programs with in the prison and
given the home. But he was
afraid to go home.
Because his home environment
was the same as when he left.
So they're keeping this young
man inside because he. He really
sees he feels Cup more
comfortable living I don't.
Not because he needed to be.
Find any longer but the
environment in homeless not
brown so we really gotta do.
Different types of work that
really strengthens. And allows
these young men and women.
Even.
Succeed even at in the
communities that.
So. For the group said
edification that just like to
say that.
You know I I think there are a
lot of these answers are in the
room.
So by the people there here in
the panel and and speaking in
everything but.
Before we close I just have to
say you know Kate can we. Try to
focus a little bit more on
leadership development.
And getting back to what we use
it in.
Which is we used to teach each
other everything that we know.
And share the information.
Everything.
And and that's why I offer you
the program that was talking
about because that was twenty
two years of public of
knowledge.
Them.
Altruistic plea. Passing down
to the people that I've never
known before but is help me to
build a relationship and create.
Place of healing and growth.
And and and and that's what
blesses me today being able to
capacity folks
so that they can navigate the
systems and take this knowledge.
And and make a good life for
themselves.
.
Them legislators.
Low when I got out of school.
No I didn't go my pups got me in
this program called and roads.
And.
In roads.
While I was in university
California riverside I mean for
a four year internship because a
permanent to pay.
And so they check my grades
every year.
After I got out at UC riverside.
I've had several conversations
with the man at the county that
hooked me up with a guy named
doctor Rodney hood.
Dodd Rodney hood pick me up from
my house.
Took me over to meet a man named
Keith Brady who was run at a
hospital.
Of on the edge of downtown. The
Duggar Keith rated and
introduced me to a man they.
Paul sams.
All Sam's that was running the
health department.
Pause hymns introduced me to his
wife and a man named Harold
tuck.
So you don't talking about.
So.
This marrow to go in and two
and a half years.
Gave me you know every piece of
what about the. Of what the
county was like.
Have middle and my first job and
now my second job my first job
was at paradise valley hospital
for. Eleven and a half years
but.
That's how we used to work.
What happened to that?
So I just offer you day.
Pretty good panel what one more
round of.
Thank you. And now we have
talked about.
Public comment
so if you want to make.
The public comment or.
Or ask a question hopefully we
can answer it.
.
Is a public meeting so we.
Give the Mike to you.
To make a public comment.
Find out.
It's.
A lot of sensation flow.
Are we to the stimulus package.
Six years old income Atty.
Turning on the side.
AB railing.
Because after that.
Jean.
Besides I saw huge five titles
on her soul.
Aha.
That was mine.
That was what I have.
Whatever the source from.
All are so by voters or online.
And I'm going to Jean
stone.
Said.
A young man with a lack of long.
I was one of those local.
City.
So how humans.
Bob I got out at age thirty two.
Often what saved my life and
voting record is education.
I'm going to Los Diego CA
economies.
And no obviously my life.
Billion severe
and also education
I here to eat and model in high
growth.
And a young age Tom and shrugs
lista routes in.
Megan function correctly.
Now I education higher education
saying.
And also have local back.
On on the part of it nonprofit
got his iron.
So it's a it's a brand new now
popular has a.
A ballot hoping those who were
incarcerated in going to college
forty.
And then once they get out
around here and.
A little.
Remains one just.
To bring.
For blood a meeting become
successful through higher
education.
And so to I love the father the
child and love all these if.
Fees they're happy.
Covers.
Because continue to check in the
size of.
It happened.
Billion each other out
said a prayer.
Now for profit.
What's gonna happen for wages on
speech
Jackie Judd off to make one.
You know in the pharmaceutical
industry.
Does he our criminal justice in
the
because you.
It's all pop profit.
So all these people are ischemic
problems.
So it's up to us in the
grassroots.
How hearing community
action
the other is gone nine
you'll each other out?
So I love these conversations.
And
gray honestly writing funny.
I have my sleep if you
holds everything
I gather.
Rolled out and up in each
seems
it's a lot of you probably.
Sold.
Thank you thank you.
Good afternoon nam Phillip Lee
but and them. Little skit to
come behind this gentleman I
mean he's got such a story which
I can't say that. My life.
Judy is been anything like him
but on one eight two it's just
say something briefly thank you
doctor Weber for doing this Vic
is so.
I am part of the first quarter
man death went through
the program.
And when I was.
Told about the program I was my
son I the time was just that
it's an eagle state I thought
well I did a pretty good job so.
But also in the.
And I've learned so much from
that program that even though
it's been.
Off wouldn't.
Daffy gimmicks you say three
years but I think it's more like
five years.
Okay and so it's been such are.
Schools of education and
inspiration from me that even
though it's been many years I
still come back.
And most of the men will be
through the program the continue
to come.
And you could just tell by who
is here.
And this gentleman here.
He can get to people.
Most people cannot get to.
It wouldn't please stand.
Some of the men will be took
program.
Leave had some tough life.
Some of the experiences resemble
the young man was spoke and I
see you with Paul Alexander.
So you in good company you're
gonna do well so thank you at Dr
Weber. I know you hot as.
And I know which you commitment.
We're gonna get the resources.
That doesn't have to be filtered
through.
And people like that scene and
miss the step.
This is gonna be something that
we could export. All across not
just any good county but across
America thank you.
Thank you.
In.
Comments.
Yeah I just want to thank those
of you came I know that.
.
The staff to put together a.
Wonderful group of persons on
the panel who have a lot of
them.
And I'm just really please that
you that you took time to come
and share this information with
us.
Mister Jones Sawyer is quite an
advocate for.
Was a man of color in the state
and. And works very hard to make
things happen and it is
imperative that we do take
charge.
You know that we do take charge
and want to. Up because this
someone is pointed out we have
all the answers we need.
And I it was interesting as I
listen to the young man talk
about all full to help him.
On the summit all the leaders in
San Diego net in in the area
public health I mean you've met
of all.
Tucker was to Sam's although the
friends of ours who for years
and of course us he's a step is
here who has always been. A
pioneer in the theory of social
service and public and probation
here in San Diego so it's good
to know that. These folks are
still around and that they're
able to help you may have always
done.
And we just have to make sure
that as they retire that we feel
there possess.
Individuals like that policy was
ill now and rebuilding himself
whose wife is still strong
health advocate in San Diego he
is to.
And we also rely upon call
floats in good guidance and
information and help.
So I just I just hope that we
look at those positions women
there.
And make sure that if some of
them are retiring I don't know.
If heroes retired took care
Eggman scheduled to you did we
tied us up on he. He's a
longtime friend in his wife and.
Family and good friends of mine
and I knew whose both retired
and so you would when you start
talking about that then you have
to make sure that we try to fill
those slots.
That we make sure their people
in those positions who not only
have a job to do what they're
supposed to do for the county.
But understand that their
responsibility goes far beyond
the definition of that job
and to really work to build
those communities and the user
resource.
Someone else and I hope we are
looking for people
to do that because that becomes
extremely important. To us that
we have it yeah. Knowledge that
is transferred from one
generation to.
I want to thank you all for
coming it's it's always good our
communities.
I I will I will give a
presentation of this if you
don't mind goals going ask
immunoassays earth of black
people do nothing to them
saying.
Yeah look and I speak.
I will we have a problem we may
not have the two dollars will we
start trying to solve that
problem.
And which I recall folks alone.
And we're all in some
and your disease.
Those things.
Really important.
Is when we give up that the.
Long as we're trying to make
churches.
Accountable a social service
organization
our our fraternities are.
Gordie's a club that I in our
community that have benefitted
from
quality education and
experiences when yet have a
commitment to the to the
grassroots. Is only when that
happens do we would do we
actually make progress.
And I'm committed to taking my
position.
Only making sure that that
encourage those activities that
work with those organs.
And as chair of the state budget
the budget.
The public safety make sure that
we really get to those
organizations in those places
that really make a.
And so I hope you will use us
not as you have good ideas and
things that are working then
don't feel like Sacramento it is
four hundred miles away but
it's.
Far.
That there's always phone calls
in fact.
You bills and when things are
working and working well we need
to do.
The men met with
throughout the state.
Because we really want to deal
with this issue of how we bill
that.
In our communities and how we
rescue Lazarev accounts
rebuilding the
how will the from the beginning
it's just that that's the best
thing to do.
Someone think love come at three
she to be here and all that
information that you've given us
and the work that you do and
continue.
California assembly select
committee.
Caller alike thank each and
everyone of you for for being
here joining us at our first
meeting
year.
Alike at first bank assembly
member Weber. And her staff for
a host.
Today.
That. We heard here today is
going back to talk to Weber
nine.
Sacramento to share with the
other.
The BMO see and I simply
colleagues yelled draft Argenta
for the upcoming year.
I discussion today will help us
identify the suitability and
effective programs that we.
As a state need to maintain.
Duplicate expanded and funded
help improve the outcomes of our
boys.
Men of color.
So I would like to invite all of
you to join me and slick
committee of boys and men of
color.
Color and B. unapologetic about
the work we have to do.
To approve their outcomes enough
talk.
Let's get it done.
Yeah. Flows
assemblymember assembly boys
manic.
Yeah.
Yeah